[Music]  let's make pickle grilled cheese all  right this is the best grilled cheese  I've ever made for the bread use  whatever bread you like the assembly is  pretty simple use whatever cheese you  like I'm using Vermont cheddar some aged  gouda or gowda as the Europeans say it  and our classic American cheese and of  course the main character of this video  pickles for the pickles I'm using kosher  and bread and butter  tablespoon of butter all right once the  butter is melted carefully place your  bread now we're just gonna gently toast  the bread in low heat so that it evenly  caramelizes both sides okay A little  learning moment for all of us so once  the cheese is nice and melted then we  add the pickles and we are going to flip  now that looks pretty good should be  done  okay so we all know grilled cheese is  very heavy and Rich the pickles really  cut through all of that it's perfect